what's going to happen is robust will be
able to do everything better than us
I'm quitting I mean all of us you know
it was really like the scariest problem
to me I'll tell you I mean there's like
something like 12 percent of jobs or
transport if transport will be one of
the first things to go fully autonomous
but when I say everything like the
robots will be able to do everything
it's definitely going to be outside of
human control I think that's going to be
tricky here is that
it's going to be very tempting to use AI
as a weapon it's going to be very
tempting in fact it will be used as a
weapon the danger is
gonna be more
humans using it against each other I
think most likely that'll be the danger
but we do want a close coupling between
Collective human intelligence and
digital intelligence
and a neurolink is trying to help in
that regard by
creating a an interface between
A high bandwidth interface between Ai
and your and human brain
and that AI risk is
I guess it's the sort of a benign Ai and
that we're able to achieve a symbiosis
with that AI
suggestion for what the optimization of
the AI should be what's its utility
function
you have to be careful about this
because if you say maximize happiness
and the AI concludes that happiness is a
function of dopamine and serotonin so it
captures all humans and Jacks your brain
with large amounts of dopamine serotonin
like if you can think of like the future
as a set of
of probability streams that Branch out
and then converge collapse down to a
particular event and then Branch out
again and there's a certain set of
probabilities associated with the future
being positive and different type
flavors of that and at open AI we want
to do whatever we can to guide to
increase the probability of the good
Futures happening I really think we need
government regulation here just uh
because this is you know ensuring the
public good is served
because you've got companies that are
racing that they kind of have to race to
build AI or they're going to be uh made
uncompetitive you know like essentially
if your competitor is Racing's involve
Ai and you don't they will crush you
that's where you need The Regulators to
come in and say hey guys
um you'll need to really you know
just pause and make sure this is safe
and like when when it's cool and working
and Regulators are convinced that it's
safe to proceed then you can go but
otherwise slow down
um you kind of need The Regulators to do
that for for all the teams in the game I
am concerned about
um
certain
directions that AI could take that would
be uh not good for the future and and so
if you have something if we create some
digital super intelligence that exceeds
Us in every way by a lot
um
it's very important that that people
benign and so I think it's important if
we have this incredible power of AI that
if not be concentrated in the hands of a
few and potentially lead to a world that
we don't want so I think if we can
effectively
merge with uh AI by
um improving that the neural link
between your cortex and the the your
digital extension yourself which already
like I said already exists just has a
bandwidth issue
um and then then effectively
um you become an AI human symbiot and if
that then is widespread with anyone who
wants it can have it then we solve the
control problem as well we don't have to
worry about
um some sort of evil dictator AI because
kind of we are the AI collectively
that seems like the best outcome I can
think of I think the right emphasis for
AI research is on AI safety we should
put vastly more ethic into AI safety
that we should put into advancing and
the first place uh because it may be
good or it may be bad but it could be
catastrophically bad you really want to
emphasize safely right so I'm not saying
I'm not against the investor yeah this
is I want to really even care about this
but I I do think we should be extremely
capitalized that means it takes a bit
longer to develop AI then I think that's
that's the right failure uh it should be
rushing catalog with the subject
if you don't know what the path is
there's no map there's no there's an
appliance nature it's not doing it which
means you're going to make false murders
a company is essentially a cybernetic
Collective of people and machines that's
what a company is and then there's
different levels of complexity in the
way these companies are formed and then
there are sort of there's this sort of
like a collective AI in in the Google
sort of search Google search you know
the where we're all sort of plugged in
as like like nodes on the network like
leaves on a big tree all in real world
feeding this network
without questions and answers
we're all collectively programming the
AI
and the and Google Plus the older humans
that connect to it are one giant
cybernetic Collective this is also true
of Facebook and Twitter
and Instagram and all these social
networks the Giants have meta
collectives the emerge scenario with AI
is the one that seems
like probably the best like if you if
you can't
Beat It join it okay I mean I do want to
emphasize that
um this is not really
something that I advocate or or this is
not
prescriptive this is simply hopefully
predictive
um because we always want to say like
well like like this is something that I
want to occur instead of so something I
think that
probably is the best of the available
Alternatives so I think we must have
democratization of AI technology and
make it widely available
um and that's you know the reason that
obviously uh you mean the rest of the
team you know created open AI was to
help with the Democracy help help spread
out AI technology so it doesn't get
concentrated in the hands of a few now
if we do have a third layer which is the
AI extension of yourself that is also
symbiotic
um and there's enough bandwidth between
the cortex
and the AI extension of yourself such
that the AI doesn't de facto separate
then
that could be a good outcome that could
be quite a positive outcome for the
future
um well I like the definition of like
the eyes should try to maximize the
freedom of action
of humanity
um
maximize the freedom of action maximize
Freedom essentially overall I think yeah
we are headed to an interesting and
different world and I hope that we can
remember that
we're all human beings and
let's just try to have as positive a
relationship as possible and and work
towards Mutual prosperity of humanity as
a whole
it's kind of like how much smarter are
you with a phone or computer than
without it's you're vastly smarter
actually
it that phone is an extension of
yourself
it's just that
the the data rate the rate at which of
the communication rate between you and
the cybernetic extension of yourself
that is your phone and computer is slow
it's very slow you will be essentially
snapshotted into a computer at any time
if your biological self dies you could
just probably just upload into a new
unit
literally it could be terrible and it
could be great it's not clear but one
thing is for sure we will not control it